genie mai is officially a mom i get
excited about this the real co-host and
her hubby rapper jeezy real name jay
jenkins welcomed their first child
together
this is the 42 year old's first child
and the rapper's fourth and in november
genie opened up to et about the lead-up
to bringing baby jenkins into the world
my guest co-host jeannie mai jenkins
getting down in her 32-week check-up so
we know the baby's healthy yeah so glad
about that but you still don't know what
you're having she then explained why
they decided to not find out the sex of
the baby ahead of time i don't want to
because i realize nichelle how many
surprises do you actually have in life
true this is the ultimate one the
dancing with the stars alum first
announced her pregnancy back in
september during an episode of her talk
show our real fam
is growing
and it's been really hard to keep all of
these secrets for you guys i am pregnant
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
after breaking the happy news jeannie
reflected on her journey to motherhood
with her co-hosts it feels surreal
because this is the same home
that i
said so many defiant things you know i
was like i know exactly what i want i
know exactly what kind of woman i want
to be and i always said i'd never be a
mom and there's so many reasons now that
are coming to fruition as to why i would
have said that then but i do know that
you never say never yes
and that love can really change you
jeannie went on to share her
appreciation for her tv family as she
expands her real-life one i gotta come
home and tell the girls that have always
accepted me at every stage of my life
have been through my ups and downs and
have always encouraged me to a place
where i feel like you all individually
always told me to that if i wanted to be
a mom yes no i would argue with you the
tv personality and the put on rapper
tied the knot in marge in jeezy's
hometown of atlanta a year after getting
engaged soon after genie gushed to e.t
over married life
oh my god married life feels 1 000
different than when we were dating
in the greatest way it's
i loved our dating life because we
really spent such concentrated quality
time getting to know each other and
making sure that we were right for each
other
but now being married
it's even more handheld with such
delicacy and such thoughtfulness because
we're in our 40s and we both grew up in
households that weren't healthy
marriages
and we also have never seen what that
looks like but in our intuition we all
know what we want we want to feel
trusted we want to feel loved we want to
feel safe we want to feel cuddles we
want to feel you know the romance and so
the fact that i'm doing that with a
partner that is like-minded with me is
the best part of my life congratulations
to the happy couple on their new bundle
of joy
[Music]
you